back in my room doing Bluffs again I
missed it the balls itch I'm scratching
it right now I'm not even wearing pants
should say that all small children
[Music]
hey what's going on YouTube it's been a
while since I've been in this room and
this is my area I feel comfortable you
guys have any idea how where it is for a
man to be talking to himself in this
room makes very difficult to explain to
women what you do for a living hi I'm
Janice what do you do for a living I
talk to myself and I try to help people
with that oh you're not getting my
number
I don't like problem when the women have
a problem me so they don't know how to
handle all this you know all the sex
thing but anyways recently is subscriber
asked I have some people talking [ __ ]
about me on Facebook oh it's so hard to
not care what am I supposed to do you
know social media is something I didn't
grow up with as a kid back in the day
when you wanted to talk [ __ ] about
somebody you either had to do it behind
the back start a rumor or say it right
in front the [ __ ] baby [ __ ] you fat
well mother [ __ ] you ugly [ __ ] [ __ ]
your mom and no pants on the boys too
far I mean the first thing that you have
to think about what somebody talk [ __ ]
about you through Facebook is what the
[ __ ] do you care and yeah I get it I
understand your high school it's a whole
different type of mentality but
seriously think about it why the [ __ ] do
you care do you realize that high school
is such a small part of your [ __ ]
life and I understand that during those
four years it's everything I gots to be
popular I gots to be cool I got a cough
seven times that right who the [ __ ]
cares do you realize that people talking
[ __ ] about you is not gonna stop that is
not just in high school alone you are
going to have to deal with that for the
rest of your life and yes there are
those people out there saying that oh
well we should stop this from ever
happening ever again
you can't do that and what I mean by
that people talking [ __ ] is like a
cultural phenomenon that's been
happening for thousands and hundreds and
hundreds of years in fact maybe even
millions I could even pick two cavemen
he's talking [ __ ] about somebody else
real hair just a painting he drew it
with cheese knuckles on and once again I
understand easier said than done but if
you spend literally happy energy doing
something else productive they're
worried about what some random stupid
[ __ ] face about you guess how much
further you would get in life it's
something that's going to happen and
when you
ask me for a certain device like that
I'm not an enabler I'm not gonna sit
there and pat you on the back and say
it's okay Johnny don't worry about me no
I'm gonna tell you the toughen the [ __ ]
up you know why because you are going to
encounter these people for the rest of
your [ __ ] life and college there's
gonna be some weight talking [ __ ] about
you and the workplace is gonna be
somebody talking [ __ ] about you when
you're married your wife is gonna start
talking [ __ ] about you know every time
your wife goes off and we suffer friends
she's talking about how [ __ ] up and
ugly you are [ __ ] look at me for
example everybody [ __ ] hates me I
give a [ __ ] if you hate me or not what
you eat don't make me [ __ ] what you fart
don't make me believe but I can to do
something that helps me out and you know
what that is is to not give a [ __ ] you
hate me I don't give a [ __ ] ugly I don't
give I should go die I don't give up at
the end of the day I am responsible for
my emotions and how I feel and you could
try to break me down [ __ ] but
you gonna fail I am the Great Wall of
[ __ ] China [ __ ] ain't nobody ever
take me down except for the Mongols but
that was a different but they try for a
very long time and at that point I don't
know my history okay I'm just I am so
confident as a human being do you
realize that when I asked a girl out and
she reject me obviously she's gay no
they usually straight I just you know
use that to boost my self-esteem I mean
what the [ __ ] I'm on here she you ever
try to hit on the girl by squeezing your
boobs and then grabbing theirs to
compare sizes just me and all honestly
if you want to take something away from
this this is the most truthful [ __ ] that
you will ever hear in your life for the
rest of your life whether you like it or
not somebody is going to hate you so
[ __ ] deal with it for some odd reason
whether you like it or not you cannot
explain why somebody doesn't like you
and sometimes they can't even find to
you why they dislike you sometimes they
just [ __ ] do but do you realize that
you have wasted your time on something
that really doesn't [ __ ] matter do
what I do if you hate me guess what
[ __ ] I hate you ten times more you
cannot hate me as much as I hate you if
there was a serial rapist behind you I
just might not say anything at all just
a little too far don't come to me to
enable your weak [ __ ] I'm telling you
right now that you are a strong
individual and you should give a [ __ ]
less about some
pitties about you as long as you are
happy doing what you're doing and living
right by your standards everybody else's
opinions should it matter what you need
to do is have a positive routine in the
morning right before tea shower get
butt-naked rub lotion on your body and
jiggle your ballsack and spread your
butt cheeks on the wall I tell yourself
you look like a sexy seal is that not
normal people do that right
yes it's been a while since I've been
back in this room I was in Sacramento
for a family emergency and it got
handled so yes I'm back in my domain
[ __ ] guess what we are under a
huge revamp right now
we are redoing the whole company you
guys don't know by now and you don't
know what go for broke apparels model is
is life is always what you make it but
it's up to you to take what you deserve
that is what that brand represents and
that is what I represent and there are
two new partners in our journey with
gopher bro that represent this lifestyle
as well who's it gonna be you don't know
yet [ __ ] but just wait [ __ ]
because the project is peekaboo but
anyways I will see you guys this
Wednesday and Sunday I missed you
[ __ ] tell me that you missed me
show me some new pics just kidding
uh-huh I don't want to see this year's
miss Christy you're in high school
college